my second car i ever bought was a low
rider chevy s10 long bed gold low
profile wheels 140 something spokes
and my dad says this guy here he's an
artist you'd love this truck you should
come see this artist i go meet the
artist i said why is he an artist he had
tattoos everywhere and it says ms-13 and
i said that this guy's with mata savatra
i said well i love the truck we did a
deal i bought the truck
a week later in hollywood i got arrested
helicopters follow me because they
thought i was him i'm like i'm not part
of ms-13 i'm patrick but david he says
no you're with ms-13 i said find proof
i'm with ms-13 it took us like three
o'clock in the morning to let us go they
really thought we were ms-13 yeah no
tats
no tats would you ever get a tat gabriel
look gangsters how though
does look gangster
would i would i get a tat uh yeah maybe
one day and if i do if i do it would
have to have a meaning let's just say
dylan wants to get one and he wants to
do with the daddy i would entertain it
but it's not listen so many times i try
to get a tattoo
i can tell the story of you shouldn't
get tattoos it's not acceptable i
probably tried to get a tattoo in the
army 50 times but i just spent way too
much money on alcohol and partying i was
always broke to get a tattoo if i
probably had 200 to my name i probably
would have had six tattoos right now but
the only reason that you don't have
tattoos because you were broke in the
army by the time i was 20 years old
i have tattoos
i have tattoos because i dream
by the time i hit 21 years old did you
ever get a tattoo on your uh gifted body
oh man
i've thought about it many times yeah i
think like i played college basketball
and everybody had tattoos yeah oh
basketball players have tattoos yeah
that's crazy i know right but then but
then after a while you know obviously
being a bodybuilder i'm like i'm not
doing that
i'm at a point in time in my life where
i feel like there's meaning to it
a lot more um just haven't found the
right you know phrase or right image
but i'm not opposed to doing it at some
point in time i'm just uh i'm just
contemplating it i think i think you
ought to get a tattoo on your forearm
that says what's your point
just remind you what's my point
what's your okay what's my point
every day i look in the mirror i go what
the hell are you doing you know what it
is though if you haven't at this point i
think you know if you don't want to get
it well after after would you get a
tattoo just one teardrop right here just
because of what happened two weeks ago
yeah it's tough spend a little too much
time with sammy yeah
[Laughter]
sorry about that sammy no tattoo i
remember being 16 south beach my boy's
like i'm going to get a
either a eyebrow piercing or tattoo
you're coming with me i'm like okay
he's like alright i'm going we went to a
place called tattoos by lou famous like
place here in miami again 16 south beach
he went he got the um
like uh
eyebrow piercing your boy sauce fainted
right no
just i'm like i believe that i'm like
i'm just oh so you wouldn't get it
because of pain i can't see no no i'm
not with pain i know this just bothers
you a little bit it was just the tattoo
shop it was just wasn't it wasn't for
you you were traumatized
and also being jewish that's frowned
upon yeah in the jewish community yeah
you know trump said three things to his
kids don't drink don't do drugs and
don't get tattoos and i'll take care of
you okay that was as well i agree with
one of those
which one is that drugs the tattoo thing
because everybody has them if you don't
have them more because it's more unique
the pressure is more for those that
don't have them than those that do have
them so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you